[Hank klibanoff] "I started the Isaiah Nixon case with no
records but, what appealed to me was that
it was a voting case a man who in 1948
had been killed because he voted. Isaiah
Nixon is shot
three times on September 8th 1948 and on
September 10th he dies. The family plans
a funeral and then the family very
quickly left town. It was gonna be a
while until they felt it was okay to
come back and when the family came back
and they're looking for Isiah Nixon's
burial place, they can't find it."
"The reason I started the civil-rights
cold cases project I just thought it was
important to to go back and look at
these and so if by examining these cases
some measure of justice can be brought
then that's worthwhile." [Ellie Studdard] "I chose the cold
cases class originally partially because
of my American Studies major, it seemed
like a class that would be interesting
and I obviously had some requirements to
fill and I would not have predicted how
influential professor klebanov would be
in the rest of my life."
[Ellie] "So when we first got to the cemetery we
got out, we grabbed notebooks, we were not
recording at the time which luckily
enough, professor Klebanov's journalism
instincts kicked in and he turned on his
cell phone and so I was just sort of
wandering down rows so I would go down
one get to the edge go up to the next
come back. When I got to the edge of the
cemetery and was about to turn, and this
cemetery is in the middle of the woods
so the edge wasn't a clear-cut kind of
grassy area it was just as soon as you
hit the woods that was the end, and I was
about to turn when I looked down and saw
this corner of cement that had been
uncovered from leaves and mud and it had
a couple letters sticking out and I saw
ISA on the corner of cement
and just below it SEP and I thought
there's no way there's no way. So quietly
so that I wouldn't draw attention to
myself in case I was wrong I knelt down
to the corner with cement and began
brushing off leaves and then scraping
away mud when I saw Isaiah and then when
I saw Nixon and when it said September
10th, it felt absolutely surreal the
whole moment is a little blurry a little
bit hazy because all of a sudden I just
knew I just knew that this was it and
that something we had never expected was
real. And there is an audio recording of
me saying I found it which to this day I
have no memory of saying without even
thinking I got up and I went over to
find the rest of our group."
(Ellie and Hank) "I found a thing that says Isaiah Nixon." "says what?" "Isaiah Nixon yea it was covered in mud"
"there is an Isaiah Nixon?" "yeah that's
what I was... because I saw something thats said Isaiah
so I uncovered the date it says
September 10th 1948" "Wow"
"there's a big smooth block it was like at the edge of the woods."
Because I noticed that all these slabs had this hand written in it so when i saw Isaiah i thought (unintelligible) ... but all
of this was covered in mud and roots
(crunching leaves) yeah it says father on the top but over
there they were like all handwritten
when they were on 1930,  so I
figured it could be..." "oh my god Ellie" and (unintelligible)
"Yes, this is April and that
says 1920, which is his birthdate"
[Hank klibanoff] "talking to her and saying I think we've
made a discovery you know then I tell
her what it is and she says "oh my goodness!"
pretty soon and I have her on FaceTime
I'm just holding up the camera and
showing her her father's... her father's
burial place that had eluded them for 67
years and her final words that day were
"I hope you're gonna give those students
an A"
[Dorothy] "it was just that close... golly."
[Dorothy] "September 10th...
(Crying)
[Dorothy] "When you first called me, I had a lot
still had a lot of anger and I think I
told you all I did, but after talking to
your group some of that was released and
I want to let you know now,  the anger
is completely released and thank you all
for that and so forth. I can just resolve
this it's been settled and then looking
at this it's just unreal."
"I can't say anymore except all that is
coming in my mind is thank you thank you
thank you that's all I can think of
right now. Beautiful group my goodness
you have to invite me to your wedding."
[Ellie] "So
after we left the grave that fateful day,
we have stayed in touch she added me on
Facebook and it feels kind of like I've
got another mom on there watching me and
whenever I have a new update on the case
I like to make sure she knows just that
we're not letting it go yet and that we
aren't gonna forget Isiah Nixon just
because we found his grave, just because
it happened two years ago, and that it's
something that really changed my life
and I always feel like she should be a
part of that".